uber now uses deep learning to predict
arrival times mew zero is used to
compress youtube videos and nerf scales
to entire city blocks amazing welcome to
ml news
[Music]
hey ho there this video is sponsored by
weights and biases today i want to tell
you about a new feature in weights and
biases which is their integration with
the openai api if you didn't know openai
has the ability that you can provide
your data and they fine-tune a gpt-3
model for you now this is pretty cool in
itself because you get your own little
custom endpoint that you can call has
been trained on your data but now you
can sync those training runs to your
weights and biases account all you need
to do for this to happen is to simply
call the sync command on the command
line and all your training runs will be
synced to weights and biases they have a
little demo collab where they
demonstrate that you can actually use
the artifacts and tables features from
weights and biases essentially anything
that you know you can construct your
data sets you can have them as artifacts
you can look at them in the tables then
you can ship them to openai to do a
fine-tuning run and then you can analyze
that fine-tuning run and the outputs of
it again in weights and biases they even
have a little demo report where they do
something like this they upload a
wikipedia data set they analyze it first
using tables then they analyze the loss
from the fine tuning results they do a
little bit of a hyperparameter search
and you can analyze those in these nice
parallel coordinate plots fully
interactively and in the end they use
this custom fine-tuned model in order to
make predictions and again they analyze
predictions using tables so if you want
to get started with big text models and
especially using apis such as open ai it
has never been easier than now check out
weights and biases they have all kinds
of tools for machine learning
researchers practitioners educators
students and much more individual use is
free forever and they have great team
plans and they even do on-prem hosting
for enterprise with that being said
thanks again to weights and biases for
sponsoring this video please check them
out and let's get into it
[Music]
the uber engineering blog has a new post
up about how uber switched from xgboost
to deep learning to predict arrival
times uber itself is a massive business
it's not only ride sharing it's packages
it's food and all of these things have
in common that at some point there needs
to be made a prediction of how long
something is going to take until it
arrives either the food the people the
packages you name it so they used to
have this big xg boost model that
predicted when stuff would arrive and in
the blog post they detailed that that
just didn't scale anymore they had more
and more data they needed to incorporate
they wanted to get more accuracy more
diverse business cases more locations so
they switched to deep learning now
what's pretty interesting right here is
that the goal isn't necessarily to
predict the arrival time however they
have a traffic routing system already
which is essentially something like
google maps you type in where you want
to go and where you are and the routing
system analyzes the individual pieces
maybe a little bit of traffic on them
and then predicts for each of the
individual pieces how long it's going to
take you add all of that up you get some
sort of an estimate now the problem is
real life is more complicated than you
can just estimate from a map and a bit
of traffic data so what the machine
learning model does is it takes a whole
bunch of features discrete features
continuous features which interestingly
they quantize first before feeding them
to the model they feed that into a
transformer model and from that they
predict a residual so whatever they need
to correct from the routing output so
they don't predict directly how long
something's gonna take they simply
predict how much it's going to deviate
from the routing systems predictions the
system itself seems fairly involved they
don't just shove all the features into
the beginning they also have some
features that come in later into the
system but i think the general principle
of taking something like a base
heuristic like the routing system and
then simply predicting the residual
might be a more general thing that i
don't see used often enough now maybe i
just don't know and it's used all over
but i do think that we could layer our
approaches much more than we are doing
right now because whenever people switch
from something classic to something deep
learning they try to just sort of do all
end to end and maybe the approach of
doing more of like a hierarchical
prediction where every layer just
predicts the residual from the last
layer might actually be better the blog
post goes into detail how carefully you
have to be with respect to some of the
features for example location is very
special feature obviously if you do
routing because you can't just encode
the coordinates because the model needs
to somehow know something about the 2d
structure so there's a location hashing
algorithm where you can trade off
accuracy versus storage there are also
various considerations with respect to
the loss where they use the asymmetric
huber loss arguing for example that
being one minute too late is much worse
than being one minute too early so this
lets the engineers tune the system in
concordance with business decisions they
also describe how they train this thing
and then finally deploy it what's
impressive is that the predictions come
back in the order of milliseconds which
is pretty cool yeah it seems like a big
jump in performance for the uber
estimated arrival times if you want to
learn more please check out the blog
post and the uber engineering blog
deepmind has released a blog post called
mu0's first step from research into the
real world now mu zero is an iteration
on the alpha zero algorithm the
difference being alpha zero still
required an internal simulator therefore
it only worked for systems where such a
simulator was available for example
games like chess and go in these games
you can do a step and you know exactly
how the board's going to look like and
you can reverse the step again you say
oh no i actually don't want to do that i
want to do something else you can use
that for planning into the future you
can start multiple times explore
different paths and so on there are
however environments where this is not
possible for example pretty much
anywhere else in life mu0 overcomes this
by building a latent model in which it
can plan forward so there's no explicit
simulator required so mu0 is more
general than alpha zero and has matched
or surpassed alpha zero in many domains
yet it still sort of lack the real world
application because even for mu0 you
need giant amounts of data to train this
thing on now it does make sense that
video compression is a really good
application for something like mu0 so
what you do in video compression is you
look at a video frame by frame and you
try to transmit that sequence of frames
over the network therefore it should be
as small as possible yet still retain a
lot of its quality in order to do that
usually codecs are used not codecs with
an x codecs with cs at the end this is a
piece of software that describes how to
take video frames or sequences of video
frames and represent them as compressed
data stream now this is not a static
function in fact how much a series of
frames is compressed is controlled by
this thing called the quantization
parameter the idea is if you have a slow
scene very static like a green
background or just a face talking you
can compress large parts of the images
and you can compress them for a long
time because they'll just be the same a
minute from now so you can crank up that
quantization parameter without losing
too much quality however if a scene is
fast moving if there's lots of stuff
happening on screen
you cannot compress the image as much
because over time things change and
therefore there's more information on
the screen even though you might think
this is not useful information
it is image information and therefore
you cannot compress the image as much
now current codecs use heuristics
engineered heuristics to determine when
i can crank up or down that quantization
parameter and that is kind of an ideal
setting for something like mu zero you
feed it a bunch of videos you say here
is a target quality that i want to reach
and you let mu zero decide on the
quantization parameter essentially for
each frame this is a sequential decision
making process you need a bit of outlook
into the future to see what's happening
later how much can i compress now what
should i do so it's very much in the
framework of these reinforcement
learning problems now i have looked at
these videos and so this is kind of the
original
video
okay
and uh
cool
all right now let's look at the mu0
compressed video
i can't i cannot see a different
so the
the bit rate the bit rate savings is is
the idea that i can't see ah i get it
okay maybe it's the idea that i can't
see a difference and they tell me that
mu0 uses 4.7 percent less bits to encode
that video sequence 4.7 might not seem
like a lot but given that apparently
most internet traffic nowadays is video
streaming this is a giant saving now i
still don't exactly know how much
overhead there is running mu zero at
inference time to do the compression but
fair to say that savings like this make
a real difference on our already
overloaded internet infrastructure if
you want to learn more check out the
deepmind blog post there's also a paper
going along with that called mu0 with
self competition for rate control in vp9
video compression that goes more into
the details of how they train the system
it uses a concept called
self-competition which is kind of akin
to self-play and it's a lot more
technical than the blog post
google ai blog has a new entry called
guiding frozen language models with
learned soft prompts also here there's a
paper going along with that called the
power of scale for parameter efficient
prompt tuning this prompt tuning is an
interesting concept of a novel way in
nlp in recent years we've had two basic
modi operandus modas operandi whatever
the first one was kind of like the bert
mode where you take a pre-trained model
like bert and you fine-tune the model on
your data meaning you provided input
output pairs and you fine-tuned either
the whole model adapter layers or just
the head or something like this and then
on the very other end of the spectrum is
something like gpt3 that is pre-trained
and will just remain fixed for the
duration of its lifetime and what you
can do is you can prompt it which means
that you have to come up with clever
things that you can put in front of your
question to make gpt3 output the correct
thing which is usually called in-context
learning this paper they're not the
first ones doing it as far as i'm aware
but it is an interesting concept and
it's taken a bit to the next level here
is that why are we coming up ourselves
with that stuff to input can't we teach
a model to automatically come up with
that stuff so if we have a data set that
might actually work so what they do is
they make the prompt input of the model
into tunable parameters so this is
trained on data so you need to have data
in order to train this but you'll keep
the model completely frozen and you'll
only tune what they call the soft prompt
so you don't necessarily determine the
tokens to input into the language model
but you do tune the input vectors so the
embeddings of the tokens if this were
the prompt now this obviously gets a bit
less interpretable and so on but it is a
cool concept and i do believe that it is
a very parameter efficient way to steer
these large language models so in this
particular paper the specific task they
tackle is sort of a multi-task training
regime where for each task they tune one
of these prompts but i believe this can
this can go further these prompts are
you can see right here it's a 20 000
parameters for a prompt and then that
can steer a model of 11 billion that is
a factor of i don't like six zeros or
something like this and i think that's
really cool because it gives us a handle
on these big models and i'm excited to
see what we can do if we push this to
the limits
walk nerf is a new paper coming out of
uc berkeley waymo and google research
and it pushes nerf to the next level
what it does is it essentially takes an
entire city block with way more cars
going around photographing stuff and
then it constructs many different
individual nerves a nerf is a neural
radiance field i have made a video
somewhere about that if you're
interested essentially it is a 3d
representation that you can render from
any angle and it will faithfully
represent things like you know when
stuff looks different if you view it
from here or from here it's not perfect
but it's really really good and the
point is no one needs to sit down and
make the 3d models you simply provided a
bunch of pictures and it figures out
itself how the stuff looks in 3d now
this used to work in a limited setting
with like one object in the middle or
one scene but this paper right here
takes an entire city block and figures
out how to combine different nerves like
different scenes together and stitch
them together they have a
website that goes along with this with
various videos where they showcase
they showcase the power of this so
notice they're not even limited to the
path that the cars originally drove on
they can just render from completely new
points of view this is really cool and
the scale of this is unprecedented if
you want to check this out visit their
websites to have many videos available
and yeah give it a try
and another post from the google ai blog
called unlocking the full potential of
data center ml accelerators with
platform aware neural architecture
search that is quite a long title but
what it describes is a paper that's
called searching for fast model families
on data center accelerators that extends
neural architecture search to also
consider the underlying hardware usually
neural architecture searches where i
have some sort of an engine like an
evolutionary algorithm or something like
this slap together a bunch of modules
and parameterize them and then i care
which of them gives me the best and
accuracy or something like this in this
particular case right here they also
worry about which models perform best on
the underlying hardware so you might
know that things like tpus and gpus
they're good at some things and bad at
other things and their general layout of
how they do computation how they do
memory access is very specialized to
certain things if you can make use of
those things if you can design models
that inherently do very very optimized
memory access and so on you can
potentially speed up models by a lot
while not sacrificing performance all
you do is you build a model that is
better able to utilize the underlying
hardware so the final result of this
paper is a model family called efficient
net x efficient net x largely matches
efficientnet which is sort of a classic
computer vision model it largely matches
that in terms of accuracy yet it is much
faster because it uses the underlying
hardware a lot better what the paper
also does is it decouples the measure of
flops floating point operations from
actual performance so people used to
estimate how intensive let's say a model
is by counting the number of flops that
a forward pass would utilize if a
forward pass would utilize more flops
then the common assumption was well that
sort of uses more compute and probably
will take longer but efficient net x
requires double the amount of flops than
efficient net does and therefore people
would say that it should take longer
however it is two times faster on the
appropriate hardware for which it was
designed this is an error rate of 400
if you actually consider flops as a
measure of performance which is crazy so
i think if anything this paper shows
that we need to rethink how we think
about performance and that maybe just
flops is not necessarily a good measure
of how we estimate model compute
utilization
this is a blog post from the flower team
flower means i need to look this up
flowing epigenetic robots and systems
this is a research group that
investigates things like cellular
automata artificial life self-organizing
systems self-maintenance and much more
this is a very lengthy blog post that
goes into detail in some of these areas
into a system called linea and into
various connections with a neuroscience
with self-organizing systems with
biology and so on they even have some
interactive demos so as you can see
right here there are these life forms
now you can spawn more of these life
forms and to be said these life forms
they are not somehow controlled top down
they're self-organizing
self-perpetuating
even avoiding obstacles they do
themselves now i can in fact draw a bit
more of an obstacle right here you can
see the evasion still works
it's pretty interesting to see what
happens if you just put multiple of them
they do have collisions with each other
you can generate attractors to which
they are going to
try to reach it
come here so if you feel tired of
supervised learning of having
centralized parameters of having a
single model that does things and has
overview and has top-down control and if
you feel like you want something
different something more emerging then
give this blog post a read as i said
it's a long blog post it goes into
detail into various systems starting
from very simple systems and then going
up into various experiments various
research papers on the topic as i said
it explains the system called linea and
much more so yeah can only recommend if
you want something out of the box
there's this tool called know your data
by the tensorflow datasets team and it
is a very very good tensorflow data set
analyzer for example here the
pre-configured query is please give me
images in the imagenet dataset that have
in their metadata a latitude above
72.09 now as you can see a lot of
pictures are in fact from sort of let's
say colder regions of the earth now it's
not always going to be right but this is
a very valuable tool if you want to
debug your data sets it integrates with
a lot of stuff i already mentioned
metadata but it also integrates for
example with a cloud vision so it will
give you statistics of what cloud vision
detects in these various images you can
also use that as filter for example now
i would only like to get pictures that
have a probability of containing a face
above a certain amount while also being
very high in their latitude now
apparently there exists no such pictures
so let me clear one of the filters and
as you can see there are some pictures
where there might be faces now imagenet
obviously doesn't have many faces as
such you can see this picture that does
contain faces contains contains them
from some sort of a print article this
tool can be used for many different
things you can analyze stats you can
analyze relations between things you can
inspect the data and especially if you
have your own data sets this can help
you discover problems with the data
discover biases systematic distortions
and so on there's a bit of an
explanation page to go with it you can
see you can filter a group and much more
however your data sets do have to be
supported by the tensorflow datasets api
[Music]
all right some helpful things for this
week uh just helpful things not even
libraries just things uh i guess the
last one was already a helpful thing uh
casual gan papers on twitter says open
ai stealth released model weights for
the largest clip models so apparently
their repo now says they've released the
largest clip model weights if you're
into clip go get them on neural
differential equations is on archive but
it's not just a paper it's an entire phd
thesis by patrick kidger and it serves
as a little bit of a textbook on neural
differential equations so if you're into
that check it out pgmax is a library
that implements general factor graphs
for discrete probabilistic graphical
models graphical models have been a
little bit forgotten at least in the
mainstream deep learning world in recent
years but they were really cool before
alexnet promised so this library among
other things implements differentiable
loopy belief propagation in jax so if
you do work with probabilistic models on
graphs give this library a try diambra
is a
arena for ai's it is multiple things at
the same time so first and foremost it
is a library essentially reinforcement
learning environments mainly for
two-player fighting games right now so
they say they feature a collection of
high-quality environments for
reinforcement learning research and
experimentation it's compliant with the
open ai gym standard and it includes
classic fighter games such as dead or
alive street fighter tekken and so on
they do have a youtube channel where
they show some baseline implementations
of reinforcement learning agents and
they do also host tournaments in these
games it's kind of like a kaggle
competition i guess except your agent is
paired up against another asians and and
then they play tekken if you're
interested check out diambra python
f-h-e-z is a privacy preserving fully
homomorphic encryption and deep learning
library this library supports a lot of
primitives in the areas of doing deep
learning on data that you might or
shouldn't have access to that is private
that is secure in some form or another
and homomorphic encryption allows you to
run certain calculations in an encrypted
fashion or transmit information in an
encrypted way such that either one or
the other party doesn't necessarily get
to know all the contents of the data so
this being combined with deep learning
is pretty cool and this library enables
that torch metrics is a project by the
pytorch lightning devs and it implements
metrics for pi torch especially for
distributed and scaled up by torch
computing metrics is often a hassle
because you need to accumulate over
batches or over different machines and
so on this library reduces that
boilerplate and lets you just track and
export your metrics in a very easy way
here is a simple example that tracks the
accuracy over a bunch of batches i guess
a batch of batches if you will so it
does compute the accuracy on each batch
but it also keeps track of all of them
and then at the end you can get your
accuracy over all of the data now if
you've ever done this you know that last
batch is always trouble if it's not
exactly full your metrics will not be
perfectly accurate and yeah it seems
like everyone on the world is just
implementing the same thing so good that
there exist libraries in taotian tweets
that their work on modern evolution
strategies for creativity has been
accepted and they've provided two new
collabs that you can try out so this
work is very special it's evolutionary
strategies that try to make these
collages of things it uses clip and
abstract shapes to achieve some visual
goals and it looks pretty sweet i have
to say so now there's two collabs where
you can try it out related to that
evojax is hardware accelerated neural
evolution in fact if you have paid
attention the collabs from right before
are in the evo jax repository so this is
a jax library that enables neural
evolution evolutionary search anything
like this and it enables a lot of cool
stuff that is kind of outside the box
for classical deep learning on the right
is one of these collages that i've just
mentioned and on the left is a little
game where the agents have to collect
food but avoid poison and all of this is
trained using evolutionary strategies
there's a paper to go along with the
evojax environment if you're interested
more and lastly reddit user jkterry1
writes that five months after taking
over maintenance i'm happy to announce
that jim now has a proper documentation
website for the first time in its life
if you don't know jim is a project
started by open ai and then abandoned by
openai
and has been taken up by an open source
developer who was kind enough to
continue this project and now under jim
library.ml you can find proper
documentation for the gym library now
given how prevalent jim still is this is
pretty cool it's clean and simple and if
you do work with jim and maybe you want
to learn something new about the things
that you've been using all along check
out this website alright this was it for
ml news this week i hope you had fun and
i'll see you next time bye bye
[Music]
you